[Music]
you're so good i'm so excited
thank you i'm so excited thank you so
much of course
but you don't understand i pray oh
that's the highlight of my career two
living breathing icons fangirling over
each other
we love to see it on thursday's episode
of keeping up with the kardashians
fans got a behind the scenes look at
kylie jenner's cameo in cardi b
and megan the stallion's [ __ ] music video
yeah that cameo cardi b reached out to
see
if kylie would be in her new video i
love the cape
you can wear this to the malibu house
you might get funny tan lines though
this is kylie's first day on the set
it's her big cardi b video debut
naturally
kylie's momager kris jenner was on set
doing what bosses do
thank you for asking kylie to be in the
video i was literally praying
to the lord every night like god
did you say hi to kylie no no yeah i'm
nervous i figured
okay okay she's so excited to see you
how sweet is that
oh yes honey chris brought the grammy
winner over to kylie and the whole
interaction is women supporting women
goals
kylie carty wants to say hi to you
you're so good i'm so excited thank you
i'm so excited thank you so much of
course
but you don't understand i pray oh
that's the highlight of my career
the two also chatted about their
daughters who are about the same
age how's your daughter she's good
she's so crazy and cardi threw some
mad praise kylie's way back
i've
but kylie's cameo wasn't without
controversy
after cardi and megan the stallion's
music video debuted last august
a petition was launched to have kylie
edit it out because
apparently some fans weren't feeling her
cameo
but cardi wasted no time defending her
decision to include the makeup mogul in
the video
oh snappity snap snap one fan tweeted
comparing normani's cameo
to kylie's
writing quote normani did all this and
kylie walked down a hall
and opened a door if that's not a
perfect visual indication of black women
having to do the most
and white women do the bare minimum to
get somewhere
i don't know what is cardi responded to
the fan's message in a series of
since-deleted tweets
explaining quote not everything is about
race
there's issues out here in the world
that it is about race that i preach all
the time about
this is not about [ __ ] race one fan
seemed to understand cardi's point of
view
writing normani danced that's her talent
kylie strutted like a model that's her
talent people just weird
cardi's response exactly
the rapper also addressed why she
invited the reality star to participate
in the video in the first place
citing kylie's kindness when cardi
attended her daughter stormy's birthday
bash
quote why did i put kylie on my music
video she treated my sister and daughter
so lovely at her kids b-day party
cardi added that her husband offset and
stormi's dad
travis scott are real close and noted
that kylie's mom
kris jenner had been giving her advice
on certain things
one thing's for sure the whopped music
video is stacked with some
seriously talented ladies
make the scene i don't cook i don't
clean but let me tell you i got this
ring